what's your process for approaching
dialog you know it's kind of instinctual
I think once I know what's happening in
the scene and I know where it's going
like what where the characters enter the
scene it's all about whose scene is it
what are they trying to achieve in that
scene what's in the way and sort of what
are they doing to try to get through
whatever's in the way that's pretty much
the template for pretty much every scene
so then it's like okay part of that is
gonna be dialogue part of that is gonna
be what they say and what they say
should be the the things that they would
believably say given who they are and
what their unique voice and way of
speaking is in that situation given
what's going on and what they want so
you want to avoid the mistake that
people often make with expositional
dialogue where people just speak
information that the audience needs to
know but they really wouldn't say in
that moment you want them to be saying
the things that they would really say
when I'm doing it it's kind of
instinctual and I'm just sort of quickly
writing what I have people say and then
maybe go back and revise it but what's
probably in the back of my mind is it
needs to be what they would naturally
say given who they are and what they
want and people also don't always just
express everything they want right the
best dialogue has subtext which means
the audience can pick up that they're
thinking and feeling something they're
not saying but what they're saying is
what they think is the right thing to
say to try to like get whatever it is
that they want or the only thing that
they're sort of able to say for whatever
reason given who they are and what's
going on but it's helpful if there's
this sense of subtext of we know what
the inner life is underneath that that
they're not saying but what they are
saying is hopefully feels real for that
character and hopefully is entertaining
and keeping with whatever the genre is I
mean if it's a comedy obviously your
dialogue is going to often be trying to
be funny as well so yeah it's not so
much of figuring it out as it is just
instinctually moving through it with
those kind of things in the back of my
mind and then of course tons of revising
going back and rewriting and revising
you know compressing you know cutting
editing the dialogue overtime well
there's certain scenes that stand out
that are great for subtext it's a great
study in that well there I mean Robert
McKee in his book story analyzed the
scene in Casablanca with Humphrey Bogart
and Ingrid Bergman where he he gives you
on the page all the dialogue in the
scene and then he explains to you what
the subtext is so that's a great that's
like the thing that stayed with me the
most from that book it was a really
helpful thing there's that scene in
Annie Hall the famous scene where Albee
is at Annie's apartment and he's looking
around it like the photos on the wall
and he's saying stuff but then in
subtitle they tell you the subtext which
is like you're a really attractive girl
but what he's saying is that's an
interesting use of negative space and
her subject is I hope he's not a jerk
like the others but what she's saying is
no really you think so
so I'm it's a comedic you know thing but
it's kind of showing you what subtext is
I think Humphrey Bogart was sort of the
master at subtext because so much of his
stuff is like sarcasm and sort of but
that there is like without saying much
there's a look there's a there's a jab
and a lot of things he's a good question
I don't know I mean I don't know how
much credit to give actors for it
because really it's in the writing to
some extent you need the you need the
scenes and the characters to be to have
that inner life that's gonna be clear
the audience but also have dialogue on
the page that is not exactly what
they're thinking and feeling you know
where you can feel the gap at the same
time it's a big part of acting I think
is to know what am I really feeling and
thinking because I'm not saying it and
what am I saying
and how I portray what I'm really
thinking and feeling to the audience
even though I'm sort of hiding it in a
way in my dialogue or I'm not quite
coming out with it in my dialogue for
whatever reason and obviously there are
great actors who who do that
particularly well do you think certain
decades of cinema have more or less
subtext I don't know about that I would
say that television writing
traditionally has intended to have less
subtext especially kind of like what we
originally think of as like Prime
Time Network dramas and comedies usually
have a lot of dialogue and the dialogue
tends to be a little more on the surface
with just saying whatever it is people
are thinking and feeling although
nowadays when we have all these TV shows
that are more movie like and then have a
different feel to them you might see a
lot of subtext in the dialogue there as
you might do in movies it's a more I
guess slightly more like sophisticated
kind of thing which doesn't isn't
necessarily present in certain genres
like if it's in if it's Bruce Willis in
die hard there's probably not a lot of
subtext right or if it's you know South
Park is not filled with subtext right so
but sort of like serious dramas you know
tend to have more subtext or just you
know I hate to use like a pejorative
that you know it's good if you have it
and bad if you don't but to some extent
that's true that it tends to be more
interesting and involving if we're
seeing people who aren't saying
everything they're really thinking
I mean fleabag I don't you've seen
fleabag on Amazon as a series that I
recently watched both seasons of and it
has this great device where this the
main character turns to the camera and
like kind of tells us sometimes her
subtext and it says it's running
dialogue with the camera which they did
a little bit of house of cards and other
shows have done it too they do it in
their own unique way so that the
audience is in on it she doesn't give us
every bit of subtext but she gives us
some point it looks and moments of
here's what she's really thinking but
she's saying something different and I
mean this in all seriousness you think
of Bruce Willis though and moonlighting
and it was tons of subtext between he
and she's simple right yeah it
depends on the genre it's not about the
actor does or doesn't do it it's about
the project yeah oh so you don't think
that's certain you think certain actors
get more roles in terms of you know cuz
you think of samuel l.jackson scare
achter and he's so great and everything
but he's just gonna say what he feels
you know and he's gonna be he's gonna
have this moment where he's gonna have
like a little mini meltdown and
everyone's gonna be kind of at his mercy
and then they're gonna kind of like do
what they he wants them to do like
certain actors seem to get seems like
more of one style and the other I mean
they may get cast in roles that are not
on subtext tea rolls more I suppose but
I don't know that it's certain actors do
subtext and some don't
or some are
and some aren't I think it more as a
writing thing it's more what kind of
scene is it because we're really talking
at the scene level dialogue his operas
on the scene level so what kind of scene
is it who are the people in the scene
and what are the agendas and what are
they trying to communicate or achieve
and what are they really thinking and
feeling and are those things gonna be in
the dialogue or not kind of just depends
on the kind of genre and the kind of
scene it is I think so aaron sorkin
maybe less subtext Gillian Flynn maybe
more with gone girl in different things
yeah that's a good point Aaron Sorkin I
think is less subtext he because he
tends to write these very you know smart
people articulately laying out arguments
for things I mean I think of like the
West Wing classically that way and so
yeah it's not yeah it's not subtext II
for the most part it's very come out and
say your opinion and argue it with
somebody it's kind of an intellectual
cerebral type of writing I think that's
engaging on that level it's entertaining
on that level and I'm not saying that he
doesn't ever have scenes that have
subtext I'm sure he does look if you
look at the social network I could
probably imagine scenes that have a lot
of subtext you know where Justin
Timberlake's on the phone with you know
Eduardo and he's saying one thing but we
know what he's really you mean you know
like there's thought that Android never
does it or can't do it it's just the
style he's most known for like from the
West Wing I think you're right is less
subtext II
you